let's go to the phones 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
see what is on people's minds today we
will start with our caller from the 9 7
9 area code caller from 9 7 9 who's this
I think I'm from College Station Texas I
just wanted to start off by saying that
I'm a really big fan of the show and
I've been you know trying to get on the
phone for like a while awesome great
we're having somewhat of a bad
connection so I'm glad you got through
and if you can get to an area where your
signal is better that would be great but
what's on your mind today oh I just
wanted to ask you may have already
addressed it in the past but in regards
to the migrant Caravan and Trump's
criticism you know of those undocumented
immigrants that you know are you know
also asylum seekers as well on on where
you just were used to them on that and
how could you know it would be addressed
in like that well so we I mean we've
talked about different elements of it
quite a bit I so number one the danger
posed by this migrant caravan has been
an absolute and obvious political
football the discussions of it almost
completely ceased after the midterm
elections when we reported on that in
the days after some people wrote to me
and said well listen everybody was
reporting about the election results so
it makes sense that in the few days
after it wouldn't come up it's still
barely coming up and now that Donald
Trump is starting to talk more about the
wall he's again starting to talk more
about the migrant caravan so on its face
it's a total political football number 2
if you are an asylum seeker then by
definition you are not a migrant
criminal you are coming to the United
States to seek asylum so there's that
group of people as well if you want to
you know there are people who are
breaking the law there are people who
are not asylum seekers who are just
trying to get in and we already have
laws about how to deal with that so I'm
just not even sure like what else is
there really to talk about you know yeah
and another thing I saw an article like
recall the sorcerer where exactly it was
from but there was in the silence
incurred who was you know already you
know at the border and he was told to go
back to Honduras and I think he was
about like 16 1618 around that age range
and he told he told basically the people
who were you know who are there that if
you went back he would die and then upon
you know going back to this country of
Honduras you know come to know that you
know that he ended up you know being
killed the reasons I I can't recall
exactly me it didn't I don't know just
like extortion or something but you know
that's kind of what you know the part of
the media that doesn't show you know the
struggles that sort of them go through
absolutely absolutely and Donald Trump
has made it you know a big part of his
framing to bring up people who have had
family members for example attacked or
murdered as Trump likes to say by
undocumented immigrants or allegedly had
that happen the other side of that is
exactly what you're describing and you
know it's all a disgusting political
football even more so than debt and
deficit as we've talked about and we
have to make sure that we don't let them
control the narrative on it because
that's how they end up sort of winning
and in in a sense I think it failed with
the 2016 2018 midterms rather and we'll
see what yeah sort of role it plays in
the 2020 election thanks for the call
Alejandra appreciate it no problem thank
you for listening have a good day thank
you